Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, fünf Spieltage sind in der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer gespielt. Höchste Zeit, dass wir hier im Rasenfunk mal drauf schauen. Jetzt hier in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 178. Ach, es ist endlich wieder so weit. Zweite Liga im Rasenfunk. Mir hat es ja auch gefällt, liebe Leute. Gefehlt, liebe Leute da draußen, die mir alle geschrieben habt. Jetzt ist es wieder so weit. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass wir über die 2. Liga sprechen können. Ich habe mir dazu zwei Gäste eingeladen. Zum einen vom Millern-Ton. Ich muss euch nicht erzählen, dass das ein sehr empfehlenswerter St. Pauli-Podcast ist. Yannick Pohl, et Yannick Pohl, heißt er auch auf Twitter. Hallo, Yannick.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, du, ich bin schon an deinen Lippen geklebt vor dieser Saison. Du hast eine unglaubliche Saisonvorschau aufgestellt mit 18 Gästen zu 18 Vereinen. Es waren sogar mehr, denn ihr hattet ja zu St. Pauli dann logischerweise eine größere Runde. Aber das hat mir sehr viel Freude bereitet. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Und ich weiß ja, wie viel Stress sowas ist. Ich kenne das ja noch aus einem anderen Projekt. Also schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, vielen Dank für das Lob auf jeden Fall.
Und ebenfalls mit dabei ist Robert Fischer. Dem könnt ihr auf Instagram folgen. Robert-KLP. Oder ihr könnt auch den Podcast hören, an dem er beteiligt ist. Das ist 1889 FM zum Yahn aus Regensburg. Damit habt ihr ja dann auch schon den kleinen Schwerpunkt dieser Folge mit erraten. Der Yahn-Podcast 1889 FM ist auch unter diesem Twitter-Handle zu erreichen. Werde ich alles verlinken in den Show Notes. Aber jetzt sage ich erstmal, hallo Robert. Ja, wir wollen jetzt mal versuchen, wie das so funktioniert mit so einem Rasenfunk-Zweitliga-Kurzpass. Ist für mich jetzt auch schon sehr lange her. Wir grooven uns da einfach ein. Am Ende der Folge wollen wir dann auch mal über den Yahn sprechen. Und sicherlich wird auch zu St. Pauli das ein oder andere Wörtchen fallen. Es gab da ja auch ein Aufeinandertreffen an diesem Spieltag. Deswegen lasst mal erst unten in der Tabelle beginnen. Wir können jetzt nicht jeden Verein erwähnen. Das werden die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen auch sicher nachvollziehen können. Deswegen, Yannick, du darfst gerne mal starten. Wenn du jetzt einfach mal so aufs Tabellenende guckst, gibt es denn da Mannschaften, wo du sagst, mit denen hätte ich da jetzt gar nicht gerechnet?
Ja, also man muss sicherlich erwähnen, Holstein Kiel ist denkbar schlecht in die Saison gestartet. Letztes Jahr oder letzte Saison hatte er noch Relegationsteilnehmer gegen Köln, wo es dann nicht gereicht hat, sich für eine wirklich sehr gute Saison zu belohnen. Man war ja auch sehr Corona geplagt gegen Ende der vergangenen Spielzeit. Man ist dann beim FC Sammbau mit einer Nutz oder Auswärtsniederlage gestartet. Das ging auch ergebnistechnisch so weiter. Heimspiel gegen Schalke 04, ebenfalls 0-3 verloren. Und auch beim SSV Jahn hat man 3-0 verloren. Das ging denkbar schlecht los. Man hat sich dann gegen Fortuna am vierten Spieltag fast belohnen können. Da konnte Fortuna aber, glaube ich, noch kurz vor Ende ausgleichen. Und jetzt hat man sich am vergangenen Spieltag gegen Erzgebirge Aue, die ja auch jetzt komplett unten drin stehen, noch gar kein Spiel gewinnen konnten, hat man sich dann endlich mal belohnen können. Und steht jetzt zumindest auf 15 und versucht sich jetzt hoffentlich auch mal in den nächsten Spieltagen da so ein bisschen rauszukämpfen. Die haben sicherlich einen sehr schlechten Start gehabt. Ansonsten erwartungsgemäß mit dem FC Ingolstadt, dem Aufsteiger, die es jetzt im dritten Anlauf ihrer Relegationsgeschichte geschafft haben, dann doch mal wieder in die zweite Liga zurückzukehren. Hatten ja letztes Jahr ganz knapp gegen Nürnberg es nicht geschafft. Die stehen auf 16, haben jetzt auch das erste Mal gewinnen können gegen den direkten Konkurrenten Sandhausen. Das wird sicherlich für Ingolstadt entscheidend sein, da die direkten Duelle zu gewinnen gegen die Mannschaften, die da mit unten drin stehen. Genau, und Sandhausen steht da auch mit 14 mit unten drin. Und größte Enttäuschung finde ich eigentlich, neben Holstein, Kiel, Hannover 96, die erst ein Spiel gewinnen konnten, drei niederlang, ein unentschieden und auch erst zwei Tore geschossen haben. Man hat da mit Marvin Dux ist unter der Woche auch noch seinen Stürmer verkauft. Hat zwar jetzt, das ist mir der Name von ihm gerade entfallen, aber zurück in die zweite Bundesliga hat man jetzt auch verpflichtet als Sturm, wobei Hannover-Fans da sich eher fragen, wer denn da die Tore auflegen soll. Und Dux hat da jetzt schon bewiesen, dass er da eigentlich der Torschütze hätte sein können beim Sieg von Bremen am Wochenende. Also Hannover muss da sicherlich viel noch machen in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen.
So, das war jetzt schon ganz, ganz viel. Sehr gut. Da hast du mir schon ganz viel Arbeit abgenommen. Also ihr habt es gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Sandhausen, Heustern, Kiel, Ingolstadt, Hannover 96 und Erzgebirge Aue. Das sind die letzten Plätze in dieser Zweitliga-Tabelle nach dem fünften Spieltag. Lasst mal kurz noch ein bisschen zumindest reinspringen, was da mögliche Gründe sein könnten, Robert. Bei Heustern, Kiel habe ich mir jetzt immer so gemerkt, naja es ist halt nach so einem Relegationsjahr zum einen gar nicht so einfach. Das haben wir, ich glaube, beim KSC damals auch schon mal sehr ausdrücklich erlebt. Und dann gab es ja auch durchaus Transfers, die da eine Rolle gespielt haben bzw. Abgänge. Also man hat Janisera unter anderem an Bielefeld verloren, man hat Lee an Mainz 05 verloren, Jonas Meffert ist zum HSV gewechselt. Würdest du auch sagen, dass ist der Aspekt, wo man ansetzen muss, um das zu erklären, warum es so viel schlechter läuft?
Ja, ich glaube vor allem am Anfang der Saison schon. Wir haben ja auch immer sehr viele Umbrüche erlebt und sind dann immer holprig in Saisons gestartet oder die ganze Saison war dann eher holprig. Das ist nicht einfach zu verkraften. Kiel ist ja unser Lieblingsgegner, das tue ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen setzen. Gegen die verlieren wir immer ganz gerne, aber haben auch mittlerweile Mittel gefunden zu gewinnen wie dieses Jahr. Ab und zu schaffen wir auch mal einen Unentschieden. Aber wir sind eigentlich durchgängig immer mit Kiel in einer Liga gewesen, deswegen kennen wir uns ganz gut. Und der Unterschied zwischen Kiel und unserem Jahn Regensburg ist, glaube ich, was mich auch so fasziniert, die sind immer einen Schritt weiter als wir gewesen. Die lösen Ablösesummen für ihre Spieler. Wir geben sie meistens immer ablösefrei ab. Und damit können die dann meistens immer auch geile Spieler dazukaufen. Deswegen sind sie letztes Jahr nicht so abgefallen. Letztes Jahr sind sie in der Liga geblieben, weil sie vorletztes Jahr nicht so gut waren und sie nicht so krass verkauft wurden. Dann aber punktuell nachgebessert haben. Letztes Jahr hatten sie eine supergeile Mannschaft, die verkauft wurde. Das ist immer der große Fluch, dass man in dem Mittelpunkt steht und auf einmal alle Scouts auf einen aufmerksam werden. Dann wird man verkauft. Natürlich haben die jetzt ordentlich Ablöse kassiert und haben einen guten Ersatz gekauft. Aber das hilft nichts, wenn man dann nicht eingespielt ist. Eine Monat Vorbereitung hört sich zwar lang an, aber da kann man überhaupt keine Automatismen reinbringen. Ich glaube, Kiel werden wir nicht da unten bleiben sehen. Die werden sich wieder nach oben kämpfen. Da bin ich mir fast sicher. Auch das Umfeld in Kiel ist hervorragend. Da gibt es keine Unruhe. Die werden da nicht lange unten bleiben. Aber dieses Zerflügtwerden ist ein Nackenschlag in der 2. Liga. Das ist der Fluch der vorherigen Saison.
Dann besser mal nicht in die Relegation kommen für eure beiden Vereine. Nur so schon mal als Tipp. Wobei, später können wir bei St. Pauli auch über Abgänge sprechen. Gewinnen muss man sie halt. Oder einfach gewinnen. Da hast du völlig recht. Prominent ist der Neuzugang. Und jetzt platzt die 2. Bundesliga wirklich am prominenten Namen aus allen Nähten. Louis Hoytby von den Blackburn Rovers ist jetzt zu Holstein Kiel gewechselt. Er hat jetzt, so wie es ich verfolgt habe, ich konnte es jetzt nur aus einem Augenwinkel nebenher laufen lassen. Er hat schon gespielt gegen Aue beim 3-0-Sieg. Hat auch durchaus schon 2, 3 gute Aktionen gehabt. Ich glaube, das 2-0 hat er mit eingeleitet. Aber das wird natürlich noch eine Weile dauern, bis er auch wieder Wettkampfpraxis hat. Denn er hat nicht so viele Spiele gemacht bei Blackburn. Aber ich glaube, dieser Name ist wichtig zu kennen. Und Fiete Arp wurde noch geliehen von den Amateuren der Bayern bzw. der zweiten Mannschaft. Das sind so die bekannteren Neuzugänge bei Heustein Kiel. Und dann haben wir ja mit Hannover Jahnick unten noch einen prominenteren Namen, der da unten drin steckt. Und Hannover 96 ist so ein bisschen ein Mirakel, wenn man geneigten Fans von Hannover 96 auf Twitter folgt. Und das tue ich, weil ich sehr viele davon sehr schätze. Dann ist das im Grunde schon seit zwei Jahren ein nicht enden wollender Fatalismus hin zum Schlechten. Man ergibt sich seinem Schicksal. Es werden Witze gemacht über Transfers und nicht stattgefunden habende Transfers. Es werden Witze gemacht über Aussagen von Martin Kind, über Aussagen von sportlich Verantwortlichen. Aber so ein bisschen bleibt das, glaube ich, dem einen oder anderen Fan jetzt schon im Heise stecken bei 2 zu 10 Toren nach 5 Spielen. 4 Punkte hat man immerhin. Ein Unentschieden, ein Sieg. Aber eben derzeit Tabellenplatz 17 ist natürlich eine Momentaufnahme schon klar. Aber du darfst dich jetzt dran versuchen, Jahnick. Woran liegt es denn bei Hannover 96? In bitte 30 knackigen Sekunden.
Ich geb mein Bestes. Du hattest ja schon meine Saison-Vorschau angesprochen. Da hatte ich mit einem weiblichen Hannover-Fan gesprochen, die in Wien sitzt. Übrigens ein kleiner Fun-Fact am Rande. Von diesen 17 Gästen von einem Auswärtigen Verein waren 9 Frauen dabei. Ich bin immer noch sehr stolz darauf, dass wir da einen hohen Frauenschalt einhalten. Der Gast für Hannover hatte dann gesagt, dass mit Timo Hübers und Genki Raguci eine unglaubliche Achse weggebrochen ist. Die sind beide im Sommer gegangen. Genki Raguci gerade für das Kreative, für den Spielaufbau ein unglaublicher Verlust. Dass man jetzt Mawind Duxch abgegeben hat. Dem, dem man hier aus St. Pauli nicht wirklich eine Träne nachweint. Aber man kann als Außenstehender die Transferpolitik nicht ganz nachvollziehen. Es wurde von Martin Kind gesagt, dass der Stürmer, der jetzt noch gekommen ist, der allerletzte Transfer sei. Da kann man nicht verstehen, dass Hannover-Fans sich da an den Kopf fassen und nicht verstehen, wie man in dieser Saison irgendwie den Ansprüchen, die man als Hannover 96er sicherlich immer noch hat, gerecht werden möchte.
Darf ich da ganz kurz reingehen? Also Tom Tribull wurde jetzt noch verpflichtet von Norwich City. Der ist natürlich eher fürs defensive Mittelfeld. Maximilian Bayer hat man noch ausgeliehen von Hoffenheim. Den haben wir ja auch schon in der ersten Liga gesehen in der letzten Saison. Das ist dann, glaube ich, die Alternative für den Sturm. Man hat mit Sebastian Kirk und Sebastian Ernst noch zwei offensive Mittelfeldspieler geholt, aber ohne jetzt jeden einzelnen Namen durchgehen zu wollen. Die alle müssen eben das ersetzen, was da weggebrochen ist. Und da muss man ja wirklich festhalten, also Hübers, Haraguchi und Dux. Das ist schon wirklich, das hätten jetzt auch nicht Hannover 96-Fans vielleicht auf dem Schirm gehabt, dass da durchaus was weggebrochen ist. Wie würdet ihr beide euch das denn erklären? Robert, du darfst gerne mal anfangen. Warum ist das so bei Hannover 96? Von außen gesehen haben die ja bessere Voraussetzungen als viele Konkurrenten in der 2. Liga. Kannst du dir erklären, Robert, wie es zu dieser Transferpolitik kommt?
Also ich spekuliere nur wild rum. Ich hoffe, Hannover-Fans werden mir jetzt nicht böse sein. Aber es fühlt sich an, als hätten sie sich mit ihrer Rolle in der 2. Liga so ein bisschen abgefunden. Vor allem auch die Kind, diese ständige Jammer um. Ich brauche Investoren und ansonsten ist man nicht wettbewerbsfähig und weiß der Teufel, das kann man in der 2. Liga sich nicht leisten. Und dann rutscht man gleich mal unten rein. Der 2. Liga bedeutet Kampf. Ich glaube, Max, du sagst es auch immer ganz gerne. Es ist ein ganz anderer Fußball als in der 1. Bundesliga. Und das muss man annehmen. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, Hannover nimmt es nicht an. Und so ein bisschen im Gefühl habe ich auch irgendwann platzt da die finanzielle Bombe. Und Martin Kind sagt, hey, wir können uns das alle nicht mehr leisten. Jetzt gibt es 6 Punkte oder 9, glaube ich, gibt es Punktabzug. Wir haben unsere Bilanzen nicht mehr im Griff.
Also, es ist eine Meinungsäußerung, möchte ich an der Stelle kurz sagen.
Es ist eine Meinungsäußerung, ja. Aber es fühlt sich so ein bisschen an, dass Martin Kind immer schaut, wo kriege ich Geld her? Und sonst wird er, glaube ich, auch nicht so drauf pochen, diese 50 plus 1-Regelung endlich zu kippen. Und vielleicht hat er sogar schon Investoren in der Hinterhand und kann sie aber deswegen nicht reinbringen. Aber das ist wilde Spekulation, ja.
Apropos Spekulation, entschuldige, dass ich da kurz auch reingehe. Ich hatte jetzt mal den Namen, den ich die ganze Zeit suche, ist Lukas Hinterseher. Da wird jetzt behauptet, dass der Morgenoffizier vorgestellt werden soll. Aber der Name geistert jetzt so ein bisschen im Umfeld von Hannover 96, das wollte ich gerade noch mal ergänzen. Und vielleicht, wenn wir schon überlegen, was bei Hannover schief läuft, können wir noch mal auf den Trainer zu sprechen kommen, Jan Zimmermann, der ja noch bekannt sein dürfte von seinem Aufstieg mit dem TSV Havelse.
Ja, und wir wissen natürlich, Havelse-Trainer-Schmiede, da kam mal Volker Finke her. Ist jetzt allerdings auch schon Schmucke, oh Gott, 30 Jahre, nee, nicht 30 Jahre, 25, 26 Jahre her ungefähr. Ja, stimmt, Jan Zimmermann, das ist natürlich, also überhaupt die Trainerfrage bei Hannover 96 war schon immer eine interessant beantwortete. Kenan Kocsak war da jetzt ja lange in Amt und da, ja, also irgendwie, einerseits versucht man lange an Trainern und an sportlichen Konzepten festzuhalten. Auf der anderen Seite wirft man sie dann irgendwann dann doch wieder über den Haufen. Das ist so meine externe Sicht auf Hannover 96. Und jetzt hat man sich aber immerhin mal zu einer innovativeren Lösung durchgerungen, wobei das jetzt schon Versuch Nr. 2 ist, würde ich fast sagen. Das Problem ist halt nur einfach, die 2. Liga entwickelt sich weiter. Und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir in dieser Saison viel über Mannschaften reden werden, die sportlich einen klaren Plan haben, der auf diese 2. Liga passt. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Hannover 96 dazu gehört. Das muss ich ehrlicherweise gestehen. Also jetzt mit meinem angesehenen Wissen. Ich gucke dann immer mal wieder die Konferenzenleben her und versuche, das alles so ein bisschen zu verfolgen. Also das ist Hannover 96, bevor wir uns da tiefer reinreden. Auch da gibt es ja viele Vereinspodcasts, die man hören kann. Auf der Patrol, in der Patrol, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, findet ihr da noch bessere Adressen, die noch mit viel mehr Zeit auf ihren jeweiligen Verein eingehen. Dann haben wir jetzt vorhin noch angesprochen, Aue, Ingolstadt und Sandhausen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt bei allen so überraschend ist, wo sie aktuell platziert sind. Und wir dürfen ja auch die Tabelle wirklich nicht überbewerten nach fünf Spieltagen. Robert, gibt es da eine Mannschaft, wo du sagst, das findest du jetzt besonders überraschend, dass sie da unten platziert ist von diesen drei Genannten?
Also ich dachte, dass Ingolstadt besser startet. Aber was mich sehr gewundert hat, ist, dass sie nicht groß nachgelegt haben. Weil sie hatten ja eigentlich für die dritte Liga schon fast eine Zweitligamannschaft, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Aber ich habe Ingolstadt eigentlich zugetraut, dass sie nochmal nachlegen. Weil, ja, um qualitativ in dieser 2. Liga bestehen zu können. Weil die haben ja auch gesehen, welche Namen da jetzt drin sind. Das hat mich ein bisschen gewundert. Aber dass sie jetzt so schlecht starten, hat mich dann nicht gewundert. Weil ich glaube, da fehlen noch 2, 3 entscheidende Spieler, die sie verpasst haben zu kaufen. Bei Aue wundert es mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht. Es tut mir wirklich leid für Aue-Fans. Ich mag Aue sehr gerne als Verein. Aber sie haben uns zum Beispiel Steve Breitkreuz geschenkt. Der ist ungefähr der routinierteste Abwehrspieler, den ich seit Langem bei uns gesehen habe nach Wastl Nachrhein. Aber Wastl hat andere Qualitäten. Aber Steve Breitkreuz ist ein super geiler Zweitliga-Verteidiger. So etwas kriegen wir normalerweise nie auf dem Transfermarkt. Und den haben sie uns einfach gegeben. Ich glaube, die haben wirklich auch eine ganz komische Transferpolitik. Die wissen auch gar nicht so richtig, wo sie denn hinwollen. Wollen sie im Mittelfeld landen? Wollen sie um den Abstieg mitspielen? Ich glaube, die wissen nicht, wo sie dieses Jahr stehen wollten. Da hat man ein bisschen Chaos im Umfeld gehabt. Und sowas darf dir in dieser engen 2. Liga nicht passieren. Weil wenn du da 1% nachlässt, dann rutschst du ganz schnell da unten allein.
Ich glaube, man trauert einfach immer noch dem kongenialen Sturmduo aus Krüger und Testroth nach, die letzte Saison für die Hälfte aller geschossenen Tore verantwortlich waren. Und wir hatten ja auch schon die zweifelhafte Ehre, als FC St. Pauli bei AWICS zu Gast zu sein. Ich glaube, die Idee ist erst mal hinten alles festzuhalten oder den Kasten sauber zu halten. Ich glaube, viel hängt auch einfach an der Person Marvin Mennel. Dass Aue sich noch nicht so viele Gegentore gefangen hat, außer jetzt an den letzten beiden Spieltagen mit einem 0 zu 3 und 1 zu 3. Aber davor hat man sich zumindest drei Unentschieden ermauert. Ja, Aue bleibt der erwartete unangenehme Gegner. Und wenn sie so weitermachen wollen, dann wird es schwierig, das hier unten rauszukämpfen.
Ja, das Problem ist ja vor allem, wenn du hinten die Null hältst, was Aue ja durchaus zu schaffen in der Lage ist. Gerade zu Hause ist ja Aue da meistens ganz gut. Dann musst du ja trotzdem vorne noch ein Tor erzielen, um Dreier zu holen. Und jetzt ist es so, zum einen lässt Aue die drittmeisten Schüsse pro Spiel aufs eigene Gehäuse zu in dieser bisherigen Saison. Ja, es sind erst fünf Spiele, also muss man noch ein bisschen abwarten, wie sich das einpendet. Aber man hat auch erst zwei Tore erzielt. Und da hätte ich jetzt auch angesetzt, bei dem, was ihr gesagt habt. Also man hat Florian Krüger an Bielefeld abgegeben, Pascal Destroet ist zu Sandhausen gewechselt. Und gleichzeitig doch jemanden wie Steve Breitkreuz. Und von außen betrachtet, wenn ich mir einfach nur angucke, man hat auch noch mit Rizzotto und Samson noch zwei weitere Spieler abgegeben. Und mit Fabian Karlich noch einen weiteren Innenverteidiger. Das sind alles Spieler, die rund 29, 30, 28 Jahre alt sind. Und dafür hat man dann Jüngere geholt. Also das sieht für mich nach außen aus wie ein Umbruch und eine Verjüngung des Kaders. Ob die jetzt dann zu 100 Prozent gewollt war, dafür bin ich nicht nahe genug dran. Ich meine, wenn man einen Spieler abgibt, dann holt man sich im Zweifel auch einen Jüngeren mit dazu. Aber das ist zumindest jetzt in der bisherigen Saison halt wirklich schiefgegangen. Und könnte ein gefährliches Spiel für Aue sein. Wobei ich das Gefühl habe, da würde mich jetzt dann eure Meinung zu interessieren, Robert, du darfst gerne mal anfangen, dass man mit dem Trainer Alexej Spielewski vielleicht jemanden hat, der da wieder gegensteuern kann. Und dafür ist ja Aue auch durchaus bekannt, dass man in den letzten Jahren interessante Trainer-Persönlichkeiten auf der Bank hatte.
Das stimmt, aber da bin ich zu wenig drin, um irgendwie eine Meinung zu bilden. Aber grundsätzlich ist es schon gut, glaube ich, auf jüngere Trainer oder unerfahrenere Trainer zu setzen. Aber halt im Abstiegskampf haben wir das auch immer wieder erlebt. Dann vertrauen dann auch die Fans den Trainer nicht. Dann muss man gucken, wie die Ergebnisse sind und wie der Rückhalt ist und ob von außen der Druck in den Verein kommt. Das weiß ich nicht. Bei Aue sind die Fans ja auch mehr emotionaler als bei anderen Vereinen. Ergebnisse würden helfen, würde ich jetzt auch mal sagen.
Das ist ja verrückt, Mensch. Bei euch in der 2. Liga, da herrschen die Bedingungen. Das ist ja unglaublich. Echt wird man da nach Ergebnissen bewertet. Also wie in der 1. Liga, wir schauen nur, ob jemand wenig Flanken schlägt und schön Fußball spielt.
Schöner Fußball ist viel wichtiger für Kommerz als Ergebnisse.
Da hast du völlig recht, aber schöner Fußball. Auch dafür muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt zur Aue reisen. Schlechteste Passquote der Liga mit 68 Prozent, den zweitwenigsten Ballbesitz, noch vor Ingolstadt hier im 38 Prozent Aue mit 41 Prozent. Interessanterweise Jahn Regensburg damit 42 Prozent, aber die werden wir erst sehr viel später sprechen. Dafür aber schon zwölf gelbe Karten abgeholt. Das ist das, was du bekommst, wenn du Aue guckst. Das muss aber ja auch nicht schlimm sein. Das ist ja völlig legitim. Dafür darf ja jeder spielen, wie er möchte, wenn es denn vielleicht irgendwann erfolgreicher wird. Wenn wir jetzt den Blick wieder vom Tabellenende lösen, würde mich die Aufsteiger interessieren. Hansa Rostock, Dynamo Dresden, Ingolstadt haben wir vorhin schon kurz erwähnt. Die stehen viel, viel besser da. Also Rostock mit vier Punkten, sechs Tore erzielt, zehn kassiert, aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 13. Aber wie gesagt, den Tabellenplatz darf man nicht überbewerten. Dresden richtig, richtig stark gestartet. Die hätten sogar die Tabellenspitze jetzt einnehmen können. Nach diesem Spieltag haben sie schon dreimal gewonnen, erst einmal verloren, 9 zu 5 Tore erzielt. Wie gefallen dir denn beide Aufsteiger?
Das Problem ist, das muss ich jetzt ein bisschen versuchen, das Sportliche von dem Emotionalen zu trennen.
Das ist viel mehr aufmerkend, als ich die Frage stellte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, den meisten wird bekannt sein, dass der FC St. Pauli und Dynamo Dresden und auch gerade auch Hansa Rostock jetzt nicht die besten Verhältnisse untereinander haben. Ich habe mich auch jetzt nicht gerade gefreut über das Pokal, über die Pokalauslosung, zweite Runde gestern Abend, wo es dann für uns nach Dresden geht. Dynamo, ohne da weit genug drin zu stecken, hat in den ersten Spieltagen von dieser Aufstiegseuphorie gelebt. Also der berühmt berüchtete K-Block durfte ja auch wieder teilweise gefüllt werden. Und ich glaube, man hat ja auch zwei der drei Heimspiele gewinnen können. Ich glaube, das war schon ein Faktor, der sie da oben reingespült hat. Du hattest ja eben auch gesagt, man darf jetzt die ersten fünf Spieltage nicht überbewerten. Ansonsten haben sie sich ja auch durchaus namhaft verstärkt. Zwei Beispiele, vielleicht Brendan Borello, den man noch von Freiburg kennt, war jetzt zuletzt in Düsseldorf und ist jetzt nicht zurück nach Freiburg, sondern eben zu Dresden. Ausgeliehen hat man Antonis Aydonis vom VfB Stuttgart. Also durchaus namhafte Verstärkungen. Aber man sieht es jetzt beim Spiel gehen in St. Paderborn, zu dem wir auch noch ganz viel später kommen, dass es immer noch ein Aufsteiger ist, der jetzt bestimmt nicht die nächsten 5-10 Spieltage da oben mitspielen wird, sondern zwischendurch auch mal seine Grenzen aufgezeigt bekommen wird. Und Hansa Rostock kann man, glaube ich, das 0-3 aus Hannover-Rahner-Sicht am zweiten Spieltag schon hervorheben. Ansonsten hat man noch einen Unentschieden gegen Heidenheim geholt und sonst auch verloren. Aber das reicht momentan nach 5 Spieltagen immerhin für den 13. Ich glaube, die werden viel über Mentalität, über Aufstiegseuphorie kommen und dann, ähnlich wie Dresden, sich vielleicht am Ende irgendwo im unteren Drittel einordnen oder vielleicht auch mit den Abstiegsplätzen ein bisschen zwischendurch zu tun bekommen. Aber bisher sind sie halt sehr gut reingestartet.
Das war die schönste Transferpolitik dieser 2. Liga mit Aydonis und Brandon Borello. Man hätte nur noch jemanden mit C und C kaufen müssen für den Sturm. Dann wäre das alles perfekt gewesen für alle Alliterationsfans da draußen. Robert, wie gefallen dir Dresden und Rostock bisher?
Dresden ist auch einer unserer langjährigen Verfolger. Jetzt sind sie aufgestiegen. Mir gefallen sie sehr gut, auch von der Spielanlage. Die haben leider jetzt McNipping, der ja von uns gewechselt ist. Bei uns hat er überhaupt nicht funktioniert, obwohl es ein Megatalent ist, da die Abwehr super zusammengehalten ist. Jetzt hat alles im Knie gerissen, was man sich reißen kann. Es ist übelst bitter. Mal schauen, ob sie das auffangen können. Aber ansonsten haben die alles richtig gemacht. Sie nehmen die Euphorie mit, haben sich punktuell verbessert. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie groß was mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben werden. In Dresden ist natürlich immer das Umfeld. Ihr merkt, ich schaue gerne aufs Umfeld. Wenn da mal drei, vier Niederlage in Folge passieren, was passiert dann? Wie geht das Stadion? Wie groß wird der Druck von außen? Ich glaube, dadurch sind sie auch schon ein-, zweimal aus der 2. Liga abgestiegen, weil die Ruhe nicht da ist. Bei Rostock bin ich ein bisschen neidisch. Zumindest waren wir am Anfang der Saison. Wir hatten sehr spätere Transfers. Ich bin neidisch, was sie für Namen geholt haben als Aufsteiger. Zum Beispiel Bärens hätten wir wahrscheinlich auch ganz gerne bei uns gesehen, von Udinese Kalcio Ingelsen zu holen. Munzi aus Würzburg vom Absteiger, einer der besten von Würzburg. Das wären so Hausnummern, die wir uns gerne gewünscht hätten als Jahn. Rostock hat das ziemlich früh eingetütet. Da waren wir ein bisschen eifersüchtig. Woher bekommen die das Geld? Ich glaube, die setzen alles auf eine Karte, dieses Jahr drin zu bleiben. Das wird trotzdem schwierig für Rostock. Sie kämpfen wie Berserker. Aber das langt manchmal trotzdem nicht in der 2. Liga. Es wird spannend sein, ob die da hinten noch reinrutschen. Aber auf die müssen wir gucken. Wenn man nicht absteigen will, muss man gegen Rostock gewinnen.
Schöne These. Das sind die beiden Aufsteiger. Es gibt noch zwei Mannschaften, über die müssen wir auch sprechen. Auch wenn sie normalerweise im Rasenfunk immer ganz gut im Rampenlicht standen. Auch wenn sie es am Schluss gar nicht mehr so sehr wollten. Zumindest habe ich das von vielen Fans gespiegelt bekommen. Mit Werder Bremen und Schalke 04 sind sehr namhafte Vereine abgestiegen in die 2. Liga. Jahnick, ich stelle dir jetzt extra die Schalke-Frage, dass du den nächsten norddeutschen Verein bekommst. Welchen Eindruck macht Schalke 04 bisher auf dich? Wenn man einfach nur auf die Ergebnisse guckt, dann sieht man zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen, ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis bei 9 zu 9. Das ist aktuell nicht Fisch, nicht Fleisch, aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlimm für jemanden, der sich ja auch an die 2. Liga durchaus akklimatisieren muss.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, das ist eine der Hauptaspekte, weshalb man jetzt gerade nur auf Platz 9 steht mit 7 Punkten. Man musste sicherlich erst mal in dieser 2. Liga ankommen, wissen oder erfahren, was da für ein Fußball gespielt wird. Man hat sich ja direkt das Auftaktspiel zu Hause dann doch noch von einem gewissen anderen Verein hier aus Hamburg die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen nach einer 1-0-Führung durch einen gewissen Simon Cirode, der sicherlich, hat man jetzt auch in den vergangenen Spielen gesehen, am Ende ja die Lebensversicherung sein könnte. Der ist ja auch immer für seine rund 20 Plus-Minus-Treffer in einer Saison sicherlich durchaus gut. Man muss aber, du hast die Ergebnisse oder die Siege und Niederlagen schon angesprochen, man muss aber sicherlich auch sehen, gegen wen die erzielt wurden. Also 2. Spieltag, ein 3-0 in Kiel ist jetzt sicherlich, wir haben ja vorhin schon über Kiel gesprochen, wenn man das mit einbezieht, kein großer Gradmesser da zu gewinnen als Bundesliga-Absteiger. Ein 1-1 zu Hause gegen Aue und jetzt am 5. Spieltag 3-1 zu Hause gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, zu dem wir eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt schon im Mittelfeld sind, auch noch kommen könnten.
Und du hast jetzt das Lieblingsspiel von Robert gerade ausgelassen. Das war ja glaube ich so der Hab-8-Moment, ein 1-4 in Regensburg. Ja, Entschuldigung, aber mach deinen Punkt noch fertig.
Nein, also ich wollte halt sagen, dass die Punkte, die geholt wurden, jetzt auch immer noch unter dem Aspekt gesehen werden müssen und gegen wen man die geholt hat. Das war mein Take eigentlich nur.
Robert, du hast ja dann bei diesem 4 zu 1 vom Jahn genauer verfolgt. Hat dich überrascht, wie Schalke da aufgetreten ist? Also dass dich das Ergebnis überrascht haben wird, davon gehe ich jetzt mal aus. Aber auch die Art und Weise, wie Schalke gespielt hat?
Ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich hätte es jetzt davor nicht getippt, weil sonst hätte ich gewettet. Aber wir haben ja den Hamburger SV vorletztes Jahr, glaube ich, oder, wann sind sie denn abgestiegen? Entschuldigung. Auf jeden Fall haben wir sie auch mit 5 zu 0 damals in der Liga begrüßt, in ihrem eigenen Stadion. Ich glaube, wir werden halt einfach immer brutal unterschätzt von Trainer, Scouts und Spielern. Und wir sind dann auch gerne mal der Gegner, wo quasi große Vereine sehen, fuck, wir sind in der zweiten Liga angekommen. Ich glaube, die werden nie wieder gegen uns so verlieren und so antreten. Aber das war halt schon so ein bisschen auch Erstliga-Aroganz, wie sie angetreten sind. Und da sind sie jetzt in der zweiten Liga angekommen. Vielleicht ziemlich gut für Schalke, dass es so früh diese Glatsche gab. Man sieht ja auch deutlich verbessert diesen Spieltag, dass man sieht, okay, wir können so nicht weitermachen, wie wir bisher weitergemacht haben. Wir müssen alles nochmal neu denken, weil gegen diesen kleinen Jahren können wir uns nicht 4-1 abschießen lassen. Deswegen hat es mich jetzt nicht brutal überrascht, aber natürlich war es eine Offenbarung für Schalke. Und was mich überrascht hat, war, dass wir nicht mit Glück gewonnen haben, sondern dass wir zu dem Zeitpunkt schon eine gute Spielanlage hatten. Aber ich glaube, dazu kommen wir dann später noch.
Dazu kommen wir noch. Wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir uns nicht zu sehr verplappern, sonst haben wir dafür keine Zeit mehr. Aber das kriegen wir bestimmt hin. Jahnik, Schalke 04 ist ja ein besonderer Absteiger. Brauche ich jetzt nicht nochmal groß erklären, warum da auch viel Aufmerksamkeit drauf liegt, gleichzeitig aber auch getrieben von finanziellen Sorgen. Das konnte man der Transferperiode durchaus anmerken. Man musste also einen Transferplus erzielen. Das hat man auch durch die Verkäufe von McKennie, Sardar und Benito Rahman geschafft. Das waren die teuersten Abgänge, vor allem Weston McKennie mit Juventus Turin. Da kam dann viel Geld in die Kassen. Wenn du dir jetzt mal nur den Kader anguckst und wir mal so tun würden, als wäre das nicht Schalke 04, als wüssten wir das nicht, wo würdest du den einordnen? Ist das dann schon klar einer der besten Kader der 2. Liga? Was wäre da dein Urteil?
Ja, ich würde sagen, man ist immer noch, auch wenn man jetzt von Erstliga-Verhältnissen weit runtergerutscht ist vom Marktwert her, immer noch einer der besseren 2. Liga-Kader. Aber man ist eben ein 2. Liga-Kader. Ich habe jetzt den genauen Kader leider aus der berühmten Abgänge schon angesprochen. Ich denke, da ist einfach sehr viel passiert im Sommer. Man musste sich da erst mal ein bisschen konsolidieren und gucken, wo soll denn die Reise eigentlich hingehen. Da muss man jetzt halt sehen, ob diese eher bessere oder obere Zweitligamannschaft diesen Kampf, der es sicherlich zwischendurch in der 2. Liga werden wird, annehmen kann oder ob man da sich doch irgendwie verspekuliert und mit diesem Kader dann doch nicht oben angreifen kann. Aber wenn eine Mannschaft den direkten Wideraufstieg braucht, dann ist es Schalke 04.
Also nur von den Namen her sind Osan Kabak und Armin Harit die beiden Spieler, die definitiv herausragen, auch aus der Liga, jetzt auf dem Papier, jetzt gar nicht anhand ihrer bisher gezeigten Leistungen. Und dann mit Matthew Hoppe, Salif Sané, Malik Chao. Da kann man für jeden noch ein gutes Argument machen, warum man eigentlich nicht in die 2. Liga gehört. Sicherlich Danny Latzer, auch ein ganz wichtiger Zugang vom 1. FSV Mainz 05 zurückgekehrt zu Schalke 04. Marius Böter, Dominik Drexler. Also es sind dann auch bekanntere Namen. Mit Simon Terau, der haben wir den, ein Zweitligastürmer, funktioniert ja auch schon wieder super. 6 Tore schon erzielt für die Schalker. Aber Robert, das ist eben so ein Gedanke, den ich immer wieder habe bei Mannschaften, die aus der 1. Liga absteigen. Wie lange dauert es, bis man quasi auch vom Kader her eine Zweitligamannschaft ist und dann nicht mehr, man hat immer noch seinen Wettbewerbsvorteil, weil man hatte quasi die fetten Jahre in der 1. Liga, die im Vergleich zur 2. Liga immer fett sind, auch wenn du auf Platz 15 gelandet bist. Aber dieser Vorteil schleift sich immer mehr ab bei so einer Mannschaft wie zum Beispiel dem HSV. Da gucke ich jetzt auf den Kader und denke mir, ja, das ist eine Zweitligamannschaft, also ohne jetzt böse sein zu wollen zu den Spielern. Und vielleicht bin ich da auch nicht gut genug informiert, aber das brüllt mich nicht mehr an und sagt Wiederaufstieg. Bei Schalke 04 kann man es, glaube ich, noch sehen an so einzelnen Namen, aber auch schon ein deutliches Downgrade verspüren, glaube ich.
Also ich stelle die These auf, dass wenn du nicht den direkten Wiederaufstieg mit Pauken und Trompeten schaffst, dass du dann schon eigentlich in dieser zweiten Liga gefangen bist und dich erst mal konsolidieren musst und durchschnaufen musst, um dann wieder den Anstieg irgendwie zwei, drei Jahre später in Angriff zu nehmen. Ja, und da halt Schalke irgendwie seit letzter Saison, seit Winterpause letzter Saison schon abgestiegen ist und ja, sich überhaupt nicht dagegen gewehrt hat, schaffen die es, glaube ich, auch mental gar nicht zu sagen, ok, wir sind jetzt der große Erstligist, zweite Liga ist nun der Ausrutscher, wir steigen direkt wieder auf. Von den Namen her müsste es Kamar de Wiesen sein, so sagt man in Bayern, erster, zweiter Platz, aber halt eben nicht von der Moral, von der Zusammenstellung, also da müssen sie jetzt auf diesen Sieg aufbauen und nochmal 3, 4, 5 Siege einfahren, um eben nicht in diesen Negativstudel zu kommen, um den direkten Wiederaufstieg zu schaffen. Und ich glaube auch, dass sie es schaffen können, aber da muss halt viel dazukommen.
Und damit haben wir eigentlich auch schon die perfekte Brücke, um noch kurz über Werder Bremen zu sprechen, den zweiten Absteiger. Wir haben sie vorhin schon kurz erwähnt im Hannover-Segment. Marvin Duksch ist jetzt der Neuzugang. Konnte jetzt auch gleich am Wochenende zeigen, wie wichtig er vielleicht für Werder Bremen noch sein könnte. Da hat man nämlich seinen zweiten Sieg nach diesen fünf Spieltagen eingefahren. Dadurch hat Werder jetzt dann nach zwei Siegen einem Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen –Entschuldigung, zwei Unentschieden und eine Niederlage hat man acht Punkte jetzt. Also sprich von den Ergebnissen her, Jahnick sieht das dann eigentlich ganz gut aus. Wenn ich mir aber alles andere betrachte bei Werder Bremen, dann sehe ich ganz oft blanke Panik, Unverständnis über die Transferpolitik, über die Untätigkeit auf dem Transfermarkt und große, große Angst, dass da noch mehr passiert, als nur dieser eine Abstieg jetzt in die zweite Liga. Wie würdest du es denn mit etwas Entfernungen einschätzen?
Ja, also ich denke, ich glaube, auf Marvin Dugsch hat man 55 Tage gewartet, bis da überhaupt mal ein Transfer verkündet wurde. Man hat sich erst mal darauf konzentriert, die teuren Spieler aus der ersten Liga loszuwerden. Hat ja Rashica verkauft, Sarjan verkauft, Agustinsson verkauft, beide Eggesteins sind weg. Da ist sicherlich erst mal viel Geld in die Kasse gespült worden. Werder ist ja jetzt auch nicht erst seit letzter Saison eher einer der klammeren Vereine. Da musste man sicherlich erst mal gucken, dass man überhaupt Platz schafft im Kader, vor allem auch was die Gehaltsliste angeht. Dann fängt man jetzt so langsam an, sich ein bisschen wieder punktuell zu verstärken. Tatsächlich war auch der zweite Sieg eher knapp. Das war ein 3-2-Auswärtssieg bei der Fortuna, wo man erst in der 96., das war ein unglaublich kurioses Spiel. Ich glaube, in der Nachspielzeit kann Fortuna noch ausgleichen und dann gibt es in der 96. noch ein Elfmeter, und man gewinnt das dann doch noch mit 3 zu 2. Also sie könnten noch schlechter dastehen, als sie es gerade tun.
Hatten aber auch ein bisschen Pech mit Schiedsrichterentscheidungen gegen Karlsruhe, wo man in Überzahl gespielt hat und meiner Meinung nach mindestens einen Elfmeter bekommen könnte. Das waren 0 zu 0. Gab auch schon die Spiele, wo Werder besser war als das Ergebnis.
Das Spiel habe ich leider nicht gesehen, aber das mag durchaus sein, dass dann sowas auch noch dazukommt. Das gleicht sich dann vielleicht ein bisschen aus, wenn du in der 96. Elfmeter kriegst und dann zwei Spieltage später einen etwas unglücklichen Schiedsrichter oder unglückliche Schiedsrichterentscheidung gegen dich hast. Aber ich denke, Bremen wird sich da jetzt schon so langsam wieder in den Bereich reinspielen, wo sie sich wahrscheinlich selber sehen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie direkt wieder aufsteigen werden. Aber so Top 5 sollte eigentlich auch mit diesem Kader durchaus drin sein.
So manche Werder-Fans atmen da, glaube ich, auf, wenn sie das hören. Wir werden es ja dann weiter verfolgen können. Dann, Robert, springen wir jetzt mal in die obere Tabellenregion. Wir wollen auf jeden Fall gleich noch über St. Pauli und über Jahn Regensburg sprechen. Du hast vorhin schon einmal Paderborn angesprochen. Über wen würdest du gerne sprechen, wenn es jetzt um die Mannschaften geht, die einen sehr guten Saisonstart hingelegt haben?
Jetzt hast du mich ein bisschen kalt erwischt bei Paderborn. Da habe ich mich fast gar nicht auseinandergesetzt in dieser Saison. Die sind tatsächlich nach vorne reingeschlichen, aber die machen leider schon seit wirklich langen Jahren gute Arbeit. Das zahlt sich jetzt auch aus. Sie kaufen gute Spieler, nicht zu überteuert, haben einen guten finanziellen Background und gute Trainer in den letzten Jahren gehabt. Das ist einfach auch ein Lohn kontinuierlich guter Arbeit, nachdem sie bei dem Erstliga-Abstieg durchgereicht worden sind und sich dann zusammengerissen haben und gemerkt haben, wir müssen wieder Ruhe ins Umfeld bringen, wir müssen wieder eine kluge Transferpolitik machen, nicht zu groß spurig leben. Das zeichnet sich aus und dadurch, dass man sie gar nicht am Schirm hatte, dass sie auf einmal auf Platz 2 rutschen, zeigt das, glaube ich, auch. Man kann sich nach oben schleichen, wenn man einfach ein, zwei Jahre gute Arbeit leistet in dieser zweiten Liga.
Und das nach dem Abgang von Steffen Baumgart, das war, glaube ich, das große Fragezeichen, wird Lukas Kwasniok als sein Nachfolger, der war vorher unter anderem bei Jena und Saarbrücken, Trainer davor im U19-Bereich beim KSC. Da habe ich mal ein sehr interessantes Interview mit ihm gehört. Wo war denn das? Im Schlüsselspieler-Podcast war das, glaube ich. Lukas Kwasniok war im Schlüsselspieler-Podcast, damals noch als U19-Trainer vom KSC, sehr, sehr interessant, was er da gesagt hat über Nachwuchsfußball. Kann ich sehr empfehlen an dieser Stelle. Und jetzt kommt Paderborn eben mit neuem Trainer. Und da machen aber einfach Sven Michel und Kai Pröger die Tore. Und man hat halt so einige spektakuläre Spiele, Jahnick. Also wenn ich mir die Spiele angucke von Paderborn, man hatte jetzt dieses 3-0 in Dresden, das haben wir vorhin schon kurz angesprochen. Wir hatten 3 zu 1 gegen St. Pauli, wir hatten 4 zu 1 in Bremen. Das sticht wahrscheinlich aus allen Spielen so ein bisschen heraus. Und das wirkt für mich als Außenstehender, der jetzt auch oft nur die Tore gesehen hat, die da gefallen sind, wirkt das auch so ein bisschen wieder nach dem typisch klassischen Paderborner Stil, den wir eigentlich von Baumgart her noch kennen. Umschaltspiel scheint gut zu funktionieren. Man kommt sehr schnell vor das gegnerische Tor nach Ballgewinn. Ist das deine Einschätzung nach? Du hast sie ja unter anderem beim St. Pauli-Spiel auch näher verfolgt. Weiter das Erfolgsrezept von Paderborn? Oder unterschlage ich da wichtige Aspekte?
Also nächstes Mal möchte ich noch ergänzen, dass es mich auch überrascht, dass man trotz des Abgangs von Steffen Baumgart da so gut jetzt schon oben mitspielen kann. Aber es mag durchaus, wie du schon sagst, daran liegen, dass man an einem sehr offensiv orientierten Spielstil festgehalten hat. Wenn du das Spiel schon ansprichst, das ist ja bisher die einzige Liederlage des FC St. Pauli in dieser Saison. Das war natürlich auch kein normales Spiel und sieht jetzt mit einem 3-1-Heimsieg für Paderborn auch auf dem Papier ein bisschen anders aus, als es war. Wir haben schon in der sechsten Minute unseren Innenverteidiger und Kapitän Philipp Ziereis verloren nach einem als Notbremse gewerteten Foul im Strafraum. Der Elfmeter, der daraus befolgte, wurde zwar gehalten, aber wir sind sogar noch in Führung gegangen. Aber 2-1 hätte den Angestracht der durchaus gegen uns laufenden Umstände auch gereicht. Man hat in der Nachspielzeit das 3-1 darauf gepackt, weshalb das auf dem Papier ein bisschen deutlicher aussieht, als es eigentlich war. Der FC St. Pauli war zwischendurch auch dem 2-2 näher, als der 3-1 Niederlage.
Okay, gut, da hast du natürlich recht, das stimmt. Jetzt habe ich mich wieder erinnert. Dieses Spiel habe ich ja gesehen. Was war denn da los? Also Paderborn aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 2 mit 11 Punkten. Dann lasst mal zu euren beiden Vereinen kommen, dass wir dafür auch noch ein bisschen Zeit haben. Yannick, du darfst mit St. Pauli loslegen, bevor wir uns dann mit dem Tabellenführer und dem Spitzenreiter befassen, nämlich mit dem Jahn aus Regensburg. St. Pauli hatte ja auch einige Abgänge vor der Saison zu verzeichnen. Woran liegt es denn, dass man das bisher noch nicht gemerkt hat? Zumindest den Ergebnissen nach nicht gemerkt hat?
Ich glaube, zu erwähnen ist auf jeden Fall, dass wir mit Timo Schulz einer der wenigen Vereine sind, die den Trainer schon seit mindestens der letzten Saison dabei haben. Also dass da so ein bisschen Beständigkeit ist, dass er jetzt schon die zweite Saison mit dem Kader arbeiten kann. Natürlich haben uns Leistungsträger, die jetzt gerade in der vergangenen Rückrunde mit dafür entscheidend waren, dass man sich eben da noch rausspielen konnte. Haben uns verlassen mit Oma Mamouche und Rodrigo Salla, den wir ja jetzt, wenn wir dann gegen Schalke spielen, werden wir ihn ja dann wiedersehen. Ansonsten bin ich bisher von den Verstärkungen, die schon spielen können. Es ist ja leider noch nicht jeder fit, die dazugekommen sind. Jackson Irvine hat jetzt die letzten Sekunden des gestrigen Spiels das erste Mal auf dem Platz stehen können. Ansonsten gefällt mir Jakov Medic neu in der Innenverteidigung sehr gut, der da wirklich alles wegschädelt, der wirklich eine gute Verstärkung für unsere Innenverteidigung ist. Es lag ja in der vergangenen Saison auch durchaus mal daran, dass wir uns hinten einfach zu viel gefangen haben. Das sieht bisher sehr gut aus. Erst wenn ich mal hier auf meinen Notizen schiele, sind es ja auch erst drei Gegentore in der Liga. Das spricht durchaus für eine gute Innenverteidigung und eine gute Verteidigung. Marcel Hartl, den wir jetzt noch von Amelia Bielfeld geholt haben, gefällt mir auch sehr gut. Und ein Spieler aus der vergangenen Rückrunde mit Eric Smit konnten wir ja auch noch fest verpflichten. Er hat schon auf Abgänge reagiert. Nicht zu vergessen auch den neuen Torwart Nicola Vassil, der eine unglaubliche Ruhe im Strafraum ausstrahlt und auch eine gute Strafraumbeherrschung hat. Also bei allen Abgängen, auch mit altverdienten Wienern, Dani Bubala, den man hat gehen lassen, Rio Miacchi und den angesprochenen Leistungsträgern aus der Rückrunde hat man sich doch so gut verstärkt, dass man jetzt solide mitspielen kann und auch in den Ergebnissen schon gezeigt hat, dass man oben angreifen könnte, wenn man das durchzieht. Das ist bei St. Pauli leider nicht immer gegeben.
Ja, aber die Euphorie ist so groß, dass du zwei Gegentreffer unterschlagen hast. Fünf Gegentore sind es schon, die St. Pauli in der 2. Liga kassiert hat. Aber das wollen wir dir sehr gerne verzeihen. Aber wenn wir schon über Timo Schulz gerade sprechen, ihr habt ein tolles Podcast-Projekt herausgebracht. Being Timo Schulz, da wurde in mehreren Telefonaten, insgesamt waren es, glaube ich, über 20, die Saison von St. Pauli live mit Timo Schulz verfolgt. Also ihr habt ganz regelmäßig mit ihm gesprochen. Und dann kann man auch diesen ganzen Tief- und Höhenflug von St. Pauli nochmal nachverfolgen, bekommt auch ein sehr gutes Gefühl dafür, wie Timo Schulz tickt. Das möchte ich ausdrücklich empfehlen an der Stelle. Noch mal der Millern-Ton mit Being Timo Schulz. Das ist ganz toll, dass sowas zustande kommen kann aus der Indie-Podcaster-Szene, um es mal so zu sagen. Und da merkt man dann auch so ein bisschen, wenn man das hört, im Grunde hat die erfolgreiche Saison, die jetzt schon wieder sich ganz gut anlässt, eben schon in der letzten Rückrunde begonnen. Mit diesem irren Lauf, mit dem niemand gerechnet hätte, wo man dann plötzlich auch in der Nähe des Relegationsplatzes war. Das sollte dann letztlich nicht klappen. Aber wo eben schon Spiele eine Rolle gespielt haben, die du jetzt eben auch schon erwähnt hast. Deswegen fand ich das jetzt eben auch nochmal spannend. Und kommt vielleicht dann noch mit dazu, dass man jetzt Guido Burgstaller auch zur Verfügung hat, von Beginn an, in denen ja große Hoffnungen gesetzt wurden, der dann aber ja kaum oder weniger spielen konnte. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Stürmerfrage ist auch in der 2. Liga eine der allerentscheidenden. Wer macht die Tore? Und da scheint mir St. Pauli mit Burgstaller sehr gut aufgestellt zu sein.
Ja, Burgstaller war quasi im letzten Winter auch noch ein gefühlter Neuzugang, weil er die komplette Hinrunde verletzt war. Das haben uns ja dann auch noch so machjenog leider in der vergangenen Spielzeit nicht so einen zumindest zählbaren Eindruck gemacht. Ist jetzt aber durchaus eine gute Verstärkung der Offensive. Und wenn wir schon über die Frage reden, wer die Tore schießen soll, muss man sich auch die Frage stellen, wer legt sie auf? Und da hat ein kleines Gestern das Duo Burgstaller und Chiré, der ja auch schon seit letztem Sommer bei uns ist, gezeigt, dass man da mittlerweile sehr gut aufeinander eingespielt ist. Ich glaube, man hat einfach auch die sehr gute Rückrunde oder kann man jetzt auch zum Teil wieder sehr gut in die neue Spielzeit mit reinziehen. Abläufe, die da funktioniert haben. Wobei, liebe Grüße an meinen Kollegen Tim vom Lerntorrent-Team, der schon eine Taktikanalyse geschrieben hat zum gestrigen Spiel. Es sieht vieles so impulsiv und gefühlsgeleitet aus, dass es manchmal gar nicht nach festen Abläufen aussieht. Aber da ist einfach schon eine gute Eingespieltheit da und ich hoffe einfach, dass uns gerade auch ein Scheree weiterhin erhalten bleibt, auch über diese Spielzeit hinaus.
Wenn ich auf nur die Statistiken blicke, dann ist St. Pauli eine der Mannschaften, die derzeit nicht viel den Ball hatte in den bisherigen fünf Partien. 44 Prozent Ballbesitz, da ist man so in einem Level mit Darmstadt, Heidenheim und auch Regensburg durchaus. Jetzt weiß ich aber, durch den Podcast, der hat mir wirklich sehr geholfen, St. Pauli wieder ein bisschen besser zu verstehen, dass Timo Schulz ja logischerweise auch erstmal auf den Umschalten-Moment setzt, so wie eigentlich alle Träne, aber ja durchaus darum bemüht war, ein bisschen spielerische Elemente mit reinzubringen, eben auch mehr Richtung Ballbesitz, Fußball, den FC St. Pauli zu drehen. Jetzt ist ja dann damit zu rechnen, dass St. Pauli, wenn es weiter gut läuft, häufiger gegen Gegner spielen wird. Die sagen, ja gut, dann macht ihr halt mal mit dem Ball. Glaubst du, dass das dann auch die Entwicklungsstufe ist, die St. Pauli in der Saison nehmen kann? Dass man das dann eben auch gegen tiefstehende Gegner hinbekommt, sich Chancen zu kreieren, ohne eben selbst in Konter zu laufen?
Also ich glaube, das Spiel gestern hat gezeigt, dass wir durchaus in der Lage sind, ich weiß nicht, ob Robert mir da zustimmen oder widersprechen möchte, aber Regensburg hat wirklich sehr eng gestanden, hat dann wenig Räume zugelassen, außer dann mal eine Verlagerung auf die Außen zum Beispiel, dass man da wirklich in der Lage war, auch auf engem Raum ein gutes Zusammenspiel hinzubekommen. Also ich glaube, das ist ein Entwicklungsschritt, der noch nicht beendet ist, dem man aber durchaus auch seit Timo Schulz da ist, angegangen ist. Und das war in der Vergangenheit nicht immer so. Also es hat, sagen wir, Pauli eher nicht so gut getan, wenn der Gegner sich hinten reingestellt hat und uns das Spiel überlassen hat. Das ist sicherlich was, was sich schon verbessert hat, aber wo sicherlich auch noch weiterhin Luft nach oben ist, wenn man an so Spiele gegen Aue denkt, die zwar viel zugelassen haben, wie du schon gesagt hast, aber wo sicherlich dann auch die Durchschlagskraft sicherlich noch etwas ist, was man verbessern muss. Bei allen Chancen, die man sich erarbeitet, also der Chancen-Wucher gestern gegen Regensburg zum Beispiel, da hätte man sich schon viel früher belohnen sollen, wenn nicht sogar müssen.
23 zu 9 Schüsse war es am Ende. Aber nur 5 davon von diesen 23 aufs Tor.
Hast du auch eine Statistik, wie viele Ecken es waren? Das waren gefühlt 20.
Das ist gar kein Problem, 11 waren es.
Okay, so ist mein Gefühl gestern im Stadion ein bisschen mit mir durchgegangen. Aber ja, das sah schon sehr gut aus, alles. Und von daher bin ich auch, was das Spielerische angeht, neben dem, wie wir ganz am Anfang gestern schon festgestellt haben, dass es auch um Ergebnisse geht, bin ich auch, was das Spielerische angeht, sehr, sehr euphorisch und freue mich auf die nächsten Spiele.
Dann können wir an der Stelle Robert mal reinholen. Also das war ja das Spitzenspiel dieses fünften Spieltags. St. Pauli konnte 2 zu 0 gegen Jahn Regensburg gewinnen, aber Regensburg dennoch weiter auf Platz 1 der Tabelle. Ja, Robert, lass erst mal mit diesem Spiel beginnen. Deckt sich denn der Eindruck von Jahnick mit deinem?
Ja, also Pauli hat uns, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, an die Wand gespielt, aber unsere Grenzen aufgezeigt. Entschuldigung, St. Pauli, jedes Mal verbessert ihr mich. Wir lernen es nicht, ja, bayerische Ignoranz. St. Pauli hat uns da wirklich unsere Grenzen aufgezeigt. Und ich finde auch, St. Pauli, wenn sie so weitermachen, Aufstiegskandidat Nummer eins, das habe ich schon, also nachdem sie letztes Jahr so schlecht gestartet sind und dann noch mal in der Winterpause nachgebessert haben und dann die Liga aufgemischt haben, war schon klar, wenn die Mannschaft so halbwegs zusammen bleibt. Und das ist es ja, eure Schwachstelle hast du angesprochen, so ein bisschen die Torwartposition noch mal viel verbessert, dass da was entstehen kann. Und ich meine, ihr habt ja auch die Fans im Rücken und das Umfeld im Rücken, also von Vorstandschaften, die kennen sich alle aus. Also da wächst was zusammen und ich glaube, wir haben gestern eben versucht, euch den Ball zu überlassen in der Hoffnung, dass ihr das nicht könnt, aber du hast selber gesagt, ihr könnt es anscheinend auch. Und deswegen hatten wir da wenige Stiche zu sehen. Und ja, deswegen war die Niederlage auch folgerichtig. Ich habe ein bisschen gehofft, dass wir uns ein bisschen zum 0 zu 0 duseln und mauern, weil unsere Innenverteidigung ist ja wirklich sehr gut. Kennedy gewinnt quasi jeden Zweikampf. Deswegen war auch so gut wie keine Ecke gefährlich. Aber dieses Tempo, was ihr da über die Außen reingebracht habt, haben wir nicht mitgehen können. Dafür sind unsere Außenverteidiger zu offensiv, um das 90 Minuten weg zu verteidigen. Deswegen hätten wir da noch Nadelstiche setzen müssen. Nach dem 1-0 wurde man ein bisschen mutiger, 10 Minuten lang. Wenn es dann noch zum 1-1 gekommen wäre, wäre es vielleicht interessant gewesen. Aber unterm Strich habt ihr das perfekt gemacht. Und ich glaube, wenn St. Pauli seine Leistung abruft, wird es jeder Verein in dieser 2. Liga schwer haben, gegen euch zu punkten.
Das geht ja runter wie Öl. Da muss Jahnick gar nichts mehr zu sagen. Das klingt fast schon zu gut, um wahr zu sein. Aber zu gut, um wahr zu sein, ist auch die bisherige Saison des Jahn aus Regensburg. Denn diese Niederlage ist der Schlusspunkt von vier Siegen in Folge mit zum Teil richtig tollen Ergebnissen. Oder eigentlich nicht nur zum Teil. Man hat 3-0 bei Holstein Kiel gewonnen, 4-1 zu Hause gegen Schalke 04 gewonnen, man hat in Darmstadt 2-0 gewonnen und 3-0 gegen Sandhausen. Das heißt, aufmerksame Hörerinnen und Hörer werden festgestellt haben, da sind gar nicht so viele Gegentore kassiert. Das stützt noch mal dein Innenverteidigungsargument, Robert. Jetzt habe ich ein paar Vorschauen gelesen und gehört auf die 2. Liga. Da war der Jahn immer eher so ein Problemkind. Das ist dann vielleicht auch wieder das Klassische, das Unterschätzen von Regensburg. Woran liegt es denn deiner Meinung nach, dass man jetzt so gut in die Saison gestartet ist?
Also ehrlich gesagt, wenn man 1889 auf einem und mich zugehört hat, hätte man das anders wissen können. Das ist auch so ein Problem. Jahn Regensburg ist natürlich so ein kleiner Verein. Da informiert man sich nicht, da schaut man ein bisschen auf den Kader, sieht, der ist nicht viel wert und dann hat man halt seine Meinung. Aber wir machen seit der Regionalligasaison einen hervorragenden Job in allen Bereichen. Mirja Sacili-Migovic ist jetzt auch zum dritten Jahr Trainer in Folge, obwohl letztes Jahr zum Beispiel die Ergebnisse nicht immer gestimmt haben. Der Weg war einfach konsequent und wir waren auch letztes Jahr nicht schlecht. Aber wir hatten halt diese Corona-Pause, danach ging gar nichts mehr zusammen. Die Mannschaft war überhaupt nicht eingespielt. Wir hatten weder davor Vorbereitung noch im Winter, was für uns sehr wichtig ist, weil wir halt die zusammengewürfelte Mannschaft davor hatten. Aber, das ist dann das, was ich gesagt habe, wir wurden dieses Jahr deswegen nicht auseinandergekauft, weil uns keiner auf dem Schirm hatte und wir haben nur Stolze verloren. Und haben halt gut nachgebessert. Die Transfers haben alle eingeschlagen. Großes Lob an Christian Keller an der Stelle, also unseren Sportdirektor, dass er da für jede Position, wo es gehakt hat, noch mal einen besseren gefunden hat. Farber perfekt eingeschlagen. Also wenn du diese Leistung konservieren kannst, dann wird er auf jeden Fall auf dem Zettel von einigen größeren Vereinen sein. Wir haben Sing wieder hinbekommen, was Nürnberg nicht geschafft hat. Dieser Kreativspieler hat uns auch letztes Jahr total gefehlt. Und ja, peu à peu haben wir uns da rangeschlichen. Und ich habe es halt im Podcast gesagt, wenn wir nicht absteigen müssen, müssen wir eigentlich mit sechs Punkten aus den ersten zwei Spielen rauskommen. Weil man muss sagen, Darmstadt liegt uns eigentlich immer recht gut. Und Sandhausen ist für mich halt einfach der direkte Ligakonkurrent. Und am Anfang der Saison müssen wir sie vor allem wegen unserer Eingespieltheit schlagen. Dass wir dann noch Holstein Kiel und Schalke 04 schlagen, ist natürlich ein Traum. Pessimisten können sagen, die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt halt auch noch nicht in der Liga angekommen oder noch nicht eingespielt. Aber da muss man sie ja trotzdem auch erstmal schlagen. Vor allem auswärts in Kiel sahen wir nie gut aus. Wir haben auch relativ souverän Rot-Weiß Koblenz im DFB-Pokal geschlagen, was bei uns immer gegen niederklassigere Vereine, sage ich mal, stellen wir uns immer trottlich an. Da haben wir souverän das 3-0 gespielt, ohne dass es großartig gefährlich gewesen ist. Und jetzt kam damit St. Pauli einfach mal der falsche Gegner zum falschen Zeitpunkt. Ich hätte mir das später in der Saison gewünschen, wenn Nürnberg vielleicht noch mal auf dem falschen Fuß erwischen könnte. Und nach der Länderspielpause ist, glaube ich, wieder ein neuer Saisonstart. Jetzt hat jeder noch mal zwei Wochen Zeit, seine Fehler auszumerzen. Deswegen würde ich mich dann auch keine Vorschau großartig wagen. Aber der perfekte Saisonstart, aber nicht so überraschend, wie es, glaube ich, klingt. Wir sind einfach unseren Weg weitergegangen. Und es sind halt auch ein paar glückliche Momente dann passiert. Natürlich hätte auch Darmstadt mal in Führung gehen können zum Beispiel. Dann passiert im Fußball alles. Aber es ist ein richtig konsequenter Weg, der jetzt zu dieser Leistung geführt hat. Aber wir werden nicht, glaube ich, da oben uns festsetzen. Das kann ich, glaube ich, so schon sagen.
Dann unterschätze da mal nicht Jahn Regensburg. Das soll denn öfter passieren, habe ich gehört von jemandem, der sich da gut auskennt. Also um kurz noch die Namen einzuordnen, die du genannt hast. Das eine war Konrad Faber rechts außen. Der kam aus der zweiten vom SC Freiburg, die in die dritte Liga aufgestiegen ist. Das andere war Sabrit Singh aus dem Nachwuchs des FC Bayern. Beziehungsweise hat eben beim ersten FC Nürnberg auch gespielt. Ist ein kreativer Spieler. Dann hast du vorhin schon Steve Breitkreuz genannt und auch Scott Kennedy, Innenverteidiger, die sehr viel Wettverteidigen mit dafür zuständig sind, dass dem Jahn bisher erst drei Gegentreffer zu Unpass gekommen sind. Gibt es noch Spieler, die du hervorheben würdest, wo du sagst, da lohnt sich ein Auge drauf, die sind mitverantwortlich für die gute Phase des Jahn?
Also immer mitverantwortlich ist natürlich Alexander Meyer, unser Tollhüter, muss jetzt nicht so oft eingreifen, aber er hat schon einige Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen gelöst, wo es dann bremslich hätte werden können, wenn wir den Ausgleich gefangen hätten. Ansonsten Jan-Niklas Beste, den wir von Werder Bremen ausgeliehen haben, die werden sich wahrscheinlich in den Arsch beißen, dass sie uns den als zwei Jahre ausgeliehen haben, weil den haben wir ja noch geholt, als sie Bundesligist waren, hat sich um 100 Prozent verbessert. Wahnsinn, wie viel besser er geworden ist, dass uns Freiburg-Bukalfa ausgeliehen hat. Keiner in der Fanszene hat sich gedacht, was soll dieser Transfer, da braucht man doch keinen. Eigentlich ist der junge Gold wert im Mittelfeld. Wer uns jetzt leider gefehlt hat, hat man jetzt auch auf St. Pauli gesehen. Ich hoffe, dass uns das jetzt taktisch nicht auf die Füße fällt die nächsten Wochen, ist David Otto, den wir ja ausgeliehen haben von Hoffenheim, auch für jetzt eineinhalb Jahre. Der hat sich ja bisher auch schwergetan als Supertalent. Nirgendwo den Durchbruch geschafft. Wir haben ihn jetzt schon ein bisschen hinbekommen. Er ist dieser Block-Spieler. Er ist zwei Mittelstürmer, schießt wenig Tore, aber er bindet zwei Spieler, legt mit der Brust ab auf den nächsten Spieler und dann kommt der Weitschuss vom Beste oder von unserem Mittelfeld, von Bisuschkov. Jetzt ist mir sein Name nicht eingefallen. Peinlich. Das ist genau unsere Spielweise, dass wir vorne die Spieler binden und dann die Bälle verteilen. Damit hat das in Perfektion gemacht, die letzten vier, fünf Spiele. Er hat sich jetzt leider im Training, glaube ich, Sprunggelenk lediert, wird ein paar Wochen ausfallen. Ärgerlich für uns, es sollte jetzt dann Zvartz, den wir geholt haben aus den Niederlanden, junger Spieler, viele gute Statistiken. Das erste Mal, glaube ich, abgelöse gezahlt seit etlichen Jahren für einen Spieler. Der sollte das jetzt ein bisschen auffangen, aber der ist, glaube ich, der ist genauso alt wie David Otto, aber halt noch nicht so eingespielt in unserem Team. Und da hat sich gestern sehr, sehr schwer getan gegen St. Pauli, aber es war halt auch St. Pauli. Ich bin gespannt, wie er dann die nächsten Spiele diese Rolle einnimmt.
Wenn ich mir die Statistiken angucke, dann sehe ich beim Jahn zum einen eine Offensivstärke. Also man hat nach Werder Bremen die meisten Schüsse pro Spiel abgegeben. Aufgerundet sind es 16. Werder hier übrigens mit 17 Schüssen, aber deutlich schlechter in der Präzision. Man hat allerdings auch die fünftmeisten Schüsse aufs eigene Tor zugelassen. Und gleichzeitig habe ich ja vorhin auch schon den Ballbesitz angesprochen, ohne dass man es jetzt überbewerten muss nach fünf Spieltagen. Aber da scheint sich ein Muster einer Umschaltmannschaft zu etablieren, nur den Statistiken nach. Stimmt es auch über allen mit der Art und Weise, wie der Jahn spielt? Und wie, glaubst du, wird sich das jetzt im Laufe der Saison auch noch anpassen?
Ja, also ich glaube, dieses Tor gegen Schalke, wo wir –ich glaube es war 1-0 –wo wir den Torhüter und die ganze Hintermannschaft gepresst haben und dann den Ball erobert und schnell das Tor erzielt haben, ist so exemplarisch für unser Spiel. Also jeder vom Stürmer fast bis zum Torhüter fängt an zu pressen und versucht, den Ball zu erobern. Also wir sind halt ein sehr eklicher Gegner. Und es kann sein, dass man sich dann spielerisch drauf einstellen kann auf uns, aber ich glaube, gegen so Powerpressing 60, 70 Minuten lang stellt sich es halt auch als gute Mannschaft schwer ein. Und das haben wir gestern überhaupt nicht geschafft. Ich glaube, wir hatten einfach zu viel Respekt von St. Pauli. Auch lessons learned, glaube ich. Zwei Wochen, um das abzustellen. Und ich hoffe, dass unser Spiel sich jetzt nicht großartig anpasst. Ehrlich gesagt, letztes Jahr war es grausig zuzusehen spielerisch. Und dieses Jahr kombinieren wir. Gibt es mal eine Doppelpassstafette. Seitenverlagerung funktioniert eigentlich. Also ich bin total zufrieden, wie es die ersten vier Spieltage gelaufen ist. So würde ich gerne durch die komplette Saison gehen. Habe ich kein Problem damit.
Das kommt jetzt überraschend.
Die Frage ist halt, ob wir es schaffen, das beizubehalten. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir unser Spielstil großartig anpassen. Wir versuchen ja eigentlich schon eben seit der Regionalliga-Saison. Da haben wir ein Spielkonzept entwickelt, das bis runter in die Jugend geht. Da war eben Ersac Zelimbegovic als Co-Trainer auch mit beteiligt. So versuchen wir eigentlich immer zu spielen. Und versuchen dann auch die Trainer und die Spieler dementsprechend zu traden. Und deswegen bin ich eigentlich zufrieden, wenn wir das irgendwie so die Saison durchziehen könnten.
Es gibt einen Fakt, der hinterlässt einen mit großer Verwunderung. In der letzten Saison war es so, wenn man sich die Tore nach Standard-Situationen anguckt, dass da eine Mannschaft auf Rang 18 in der zweiten Liga lag. Und zwar der Jahn aus Regensburg. 5 Tore nur nach Standard-Situationen erzielt. Und jetzt nach 5 Spieltagen in dieser Saison schon 6 Tore nach Standard-Situationen erzielt. Mit weitem Vorsprung Rang 1 in der 2. Bundesliga und ja auch die Hälfte der 12 erzierten Tore. Was hat sich da verändert? Kann man das festmachen an Personalien, an Freistoßvarianten, an Eckballvarianten? Gibt es da einen Unterschied, der erkennbar ist?
Ja, also anscheinend hat man sich da einen Spezialisten gekauft oder geliehen mit Sabrit Singh. Singh macht eigentlich jetzt fast alle Freistoße und Ecken oder Niklas Beste. Und Niklas Beste hat letzte Saison zwar auch ab und zu mal getreten, aber selten und anscheinend haben sie das jetzt einfach in der Vorbereitung öfters geübt, auch wenn mehr seit dem Doppelpass gesagt hat, wir haben es nicht mehr geübt. Und Christian Keller hat irgendwie gemeint, so viele Standards haben wir letztes Jahr noch nie geübt, seitdem er beim Jahn ist. Aber es hat halt einfach nicht funktioniert. Da waren die Schützen nicht da, da war das Selbstvertrauen nicht da. Und diese Saison klappt es halt dann einfach. Und wie gesagt, Singen hat echt ein feines Füßchen. Also wenn der ausfällt, haben wir dann wahrscheinlich wieder eine Schwäche in den Standards.
Okay, also dann können wir es an der Personalier festmachen. Ich glaube, da weinen so manche Fans von Vereinen, die das nicht hinbekommen, dass du sagst, ja, wir haben es halt einfach, es läuft halt jetzt einfach. Wir haben hier die richtigen Leute. Lass noch ganz kurz das größere Bild ausmachen vom SSV. Da wird ja jetzt nicht allen ein Begriff sein, wie da die Situation ist. Wenn ich mir mal die Finanzkennzahlen angucke, da haben wir natürlich die vom letzten Jahr schon vorliegen, 1920 die Saison, dann sehe ich, Jahn Regensburg führt die Tabelle aller Profivereine an. Und zwar in der Kategorie der Verbindlichkeiten. Der Jahn hat nämlich fast keine 1 Mio. Euro Verbindlichkeiten in der Saison 1920. Allerdings auch sehr geringe Bilanzsumme. Das Rohergebnis ist nicht allzu hoch. Und der Personalaufwand, also das, was man investieren kann in Gehälter für Mitarbeiterinnen und die Spieler, da ist man auf Rang 39 aller Bundesligisten der ersten und der zweiten Liga, also sehr weit hinten angesiedelt. Wie ist die Situation bei Regensburg? Wie ist die finanzielle Lage? Und wie stabil steht der Club da?
Also wir stehen, glaube ich, finanziell sehr stabil da, eben weil wir keine Verbindlichkeiten haben, weil wir in den letzten fünf Jahren brutal in unsere Infrastruktur investiert haben. Und das ist ja der Weg, den wir gehen mussten eigentlich. Also wenn man mal zurückschaut, bei der letzten Zweitligasaison konnten wir uns fast das Stadion nicht leisten. Es war eine Riesenherausforderung, die Stadionheizung zu installieren, also 2012, 2013. Da hatten wir überhaupt kein Geld, irgendwie in den Kader zu stecken, weil wir alles ins Stadion stecken mussten. Dann haben wir eben unser neues Schmuckstück bekommen, das die Stadt gebaut hat, und wir mieten uns da rein. Und dann sind wir abgestiegen in die Regionalliga. Das hat uns auch so ein bisschen geholfen, glaube ich, konsolidierungsmäßig. Aber natürlich mussten wir unbedingt aufsteigen. Das haben wir dann geschafft. Christian Keller ist halt auch ein guter BWLer. Wir haben ein sehr schlechtes Trainingsgelände gehabt. Das haben wir jetzt die letzten 5, 6 Jahre auf Vordermann gebracht. Dafür muss man natürlich Gewinne erzielen, wenn man es nicht mit Fremdkapital finanzieren möchte. Aber aufgrund unserer Historie, uns wurde schon mal der Strom abgeschaltet, kann man in Regensburg keine Taktik fahren, die auf Verschuldung oder auf Investition aus ist, weil das das Umfeld nicht hergibt und die Politik auch nicht. Das würde keiner mitmachen. Deswegen eben diese seriöse Wirtschaften. Wir versuchen so zwischen 5 und 6 Millionen Euro im Jahr Gewinn zu machen, um das in dieses Trainingsgelände zu stecken. Da haben wir jetzt wirklich ein sehr, sehr geiles Trainingsgelände für Jahnverhältnisse. Das nächste wird eine Jugendakademie sein. Das heißt, wir werden diesen Weg mit wenig Personalaufwand, viel Gewinne, um diese dann wieder zu reinvestieren, noch einige Jahre beim Jahn sehen. Deswegen, glaube ich, passt es auch bei den Spielern, die wissen, auf was sie sich einlassen, dass sie nicht reich werden, wenn sie beim Jahn spielen, dass es aber ein gutes Sprungbrett ist, dass die Stimmung hier gut ist. Das Gehaltsgefüge ist, glaube ich, noch nicht so wie bei anderen Vereinen. Jeder verdient in etwa das Gleiche. Natürlich wird es Ausreißer nach oben und nach unten geben, aber wenn die Leute sich in den Kabinen unterhalten, wird es keinen geben, der, weiß ich nicht, eineinhalb Millionen verdient, unter anderem nur 100.000. Also da kommt es auch nicht zu Neid. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen unser Erfolgskonzept. Aber unser Aufsichtsratvorsitzender hat dann gemeint, wir wollen uns in den Top 50 der deutschen Mannschaften etablieren. Und ich glaube, das haben wir eindrucksvoll geschafft.
Mensch, ein wunderbares Schlusswort. Ich könnte noch ganz lange mit euch beiden reden. Wir haben natürlich auch nicht alle Vereine jetzt ansprechen können, aber da werden wir noch weitere Ausgaben hier im Kurzbach machen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und wenn ihr enttäuscht seid, mag ich nur noch mal darauf hinweisen, es gibt ganz fantastische Vereinspodcasts unter rasenfunk.de/patrolkönntihr die hören und da könnt ihr euch zu den einzelnen Vereinen noch informieren. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Ich möchte euch verabschieden mit meiner absoluten, absoluten, absoluten Lieblingsstatistik nach fünf Spieltagen in dieser zweiten Bundesliga. Gewonnene Kopfballduelle, die Rangliste Werder Bremen ist letzter mit 15. Und wer hat die meisten Kopfballduelle pro Spiel gewonnen? Mögt ihr raten? Yannick, hast du eine Idee?
Naja, wenn wir jetzt eben die Verteidigung vom Jan schon angesprochen haben und auch gestern die die zahlreichen Ecken wurden alle irgendwie weggeschädelt, hätte ich jetzt gesagt, dass es auch da der Spitzenreiter ist.
Robert? Ja, würde ich auch sagen. Ich glaube auch Kennedy wird da ganz oben mit dabei sein.
Na, da liegt er leider beide daneben. Der Jan liegt da genau in der Mitte auf Rang 10. Platz 1 ist Heidenheim mit 32 gewonnenen Kopfballduellen pro Spiel. Es ist unfassbar. Heidenheim auch eine Standardmannschaft. Aber das wird sich noch so ein bisschen runter regeln, das ist mir schon klar jetzt im Verlauf der Saison. Aber 32 Kopfballduelle pro Spiel, das ist für mich zweite Liga. Das ist ja, so gehört es sich einfach. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Ich danke euch für eure Zeit. Zum einen, Yannick Pohl. Yannick Pohl heißt da auch auf Twitter. Vom Millan-Ton, der Millan-Ton, sehr ausführlich. Nicht nur zum FC St. Pauli, sondern auch durch die Gegnerbeobachtungen bekommt man da eigentlich auch einen ganz guten Gesamtüberblick über die Liga im Verlauf der Saison. Yannick, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du mal mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Ja, nochmal vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und ich möchte nicht vergessen zu erwähnen, was ich in der SSV-Segment getan habe, dass der SSV weiterhin Stadtmeister in Hamburg ist.
Ja, gut, dass du das nochmal geklärt hast. Jetzt haben sich die ganzen HSV-Fans, die zurecht fragen, warum wurde über den HSV nicht gesprochen, haben noch einen mitbekommen. Nun ja, so ist das. Und dann ganz herzlichen Dank an Robert Fischer. Als 1889 unterstrich.fm kann man dem Podcast folgen, bei dem er auch mit zu Gast ist. Auf Instagram ist er der robert-klp. Robert, danke dir, dass du uns in die Welt des SSV-Jahnen eingeführt hast.
Es war mir eine große Ehre, hier zu sein, dass der kleine Jan im großen Rasenfunk sein darf.
Also danke euch beiden und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie ihr das untertun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de und ich bitte euch, tut das auch, denn wir wollen auch andere am Erfolg teilhaben lassen. Es gibt jetzt schon Gäste, Honorare und wir planen noch vieles mehr. In diesem Sinne vielen Dank für alle, die das schon tun. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!